BUT NOW, AS CNN'S JASON CARROLL
REPORTS, McMAHON'S DAUGHTER WILL
STEP IN AS THE COMPANY'S INTERIM
CEO.
>> PLEASE WELCOME THE CHAIRMAN
OF WWE, VINCE McMAHON!
>> LARGER THAN LIFE, VINCE
McMAHON, MORE FAMOUS THAN SOME
OF THE WRESTLING STARS HE HELPED
CREATE.
>> HE'S THE GUY.
I MEAN, HE'S -- IT'S THE WWE IS
VINCE McMAHON.
YOU CAN'T SEPARATE THEM.
>> WRESTLE MANIA.
>> NOW, McMAHON FORCED TO STEP
BACK FROM HIS ROLE AS CHAIRMAN
AND CEO OF WORLD WRESTLING
ENTERTAINMENT, WWE.
WHILE THE COMPANY'S BOARD
INVESTIGATES MISCONDUCT CLAIMS
AGAINST HIM.
HIS DAUGHTER, HIS INTERIM
REPLACEMENT.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTING McMAHON PAID A FORMER
EMPLOYEE WHO HE ALLEGEDLY HAD AN
AFFAIR WITH, $3 MILLION TO KEEP
HER QUIET.
ACCORDING TO THE JOURNAL, THE
SEPARATION AGREEMENT PREVENTS
HER FROM DISCUSSING HER
RELATIONSHIP.
THE INVESTIGATION ALSO LOOKING
AT OTHER NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS INVOLVING MISCONDUCT
CLAIMS AGAINST McMAHON AND
ANOTHER EXECUTIVE.
>> WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERED BOYS WILL BE BOYS,
WHICH WRESTLING WAS BUILT ON FOR
DECADES AND DECADES AND DECADES,
BY TODAY'S STANDARDS, IT'S NOT
QUITE AS MUCH.
>> I PLEDGE MY COMPLETE
COOPERATION TO THE INVESTIGATION
BY THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE,
McMAHON SAID IN A STATEMENT, AND
I HAVE ALSO PLEDGED TO ACCEPT
THE FINDINGS AND OUTCOME OF THE
INVESTIGATION, WHATEVER THEY
ARE.
WRESTLING JOURNALIST DAVE
MELTSER SAYS IT'S TOUGH TO
PREDICT THE FALLOUT FROM THE
ALLEGATIONS.
>> THEIR BIG DEFENSE IS ANY
MONEY HE PAID, ANY HUSH MONEY HE
PAID WAS HIS OWN MONEY AND NOT
COMPANY MONEY.
THAT'S THE KEY TO THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> OVER DECADES, McMAHON TURNED
THE WWE INTO A BILLION-DOLLAR
ENTERTAINMENT JUGGERNAUT.
INCLUDING DEALS WITH FOX AND
NBC.
HE WILL STILL BE IN CHARGE OF
CREATIVE CONTENT, WHILE THE
INVESTIGATION IS UNDER WAY.
McMAHON HAS WEATHERED PAST
SCANDALS.
IN 1994, A JURY ACQUITTED HIM OF
CONSPIRING TO DISTRIBUTE
STEROIDS TO HIS WRESTLERS.
IN THE YEARS FOLLOWING, ALWAYS
CENTER STAGE AND ALWAYS THE
SHOWMAN.
>> OH, NO.
>> IN 2007, THEN REALITY TV STAR
DONALD TRUMP SHAVED McMAHON'S
HEAD IN A MADE F